the following conversation occurred at
the lyceum Miami live event March 4th at
the Miami Beach Convention Center these
four individuals are some of the top
earning folks from the adult film
industry we have Brandi Love Lisa Ann
Eva lovia and Damon dice now these four
people are pioneers in both technology
adoption business and their investment
portfolios what you are about to hear is
going to be a fascinating conversation
in where technology comes from how to
identify Trends early and what these
four individuals have been able to do
that is absolutely going to blow your
mind here is my conversation with four
of the top earning porn stars in history
[Music]
great place to start would be with a
direct connection to the finance world
which most people won't uh think of here
does anybody in the audience know Jesse
Livermore
the stock market operator the book
anybody yes
so Brandy is actually the great
granddaughter of Jesse Livermore which
is one of those facts that when I
learned it I was like I had no idea so I
think that that is a great starting
point of maybe
how each one of you if we can just kind
of go down the line we will start with
uh with Damon not Eva even very very
nervous
and what I'd love to hear is how you
think about uh the adult film industry
as a business and then we'll get to kind
of the business and investment stuff you
guys do outside of the industry but like
that is an area that I think most people
are like okay porn people watch it no
one likes to talk about it but there is
a massive multi-billion dollar industry
that play there it's like how have you
thought about that uh aspect of your
life was uh Kathy Wood was talking about
earlier porn's a big innovator of a lot
of Technologies in ways that we live our
life
um credit card processors the internet
camera systems webcams VR so a lot of a
lot of the emerging technologies have
come from the adult industry being the
first ones to really take a dive at it
so what's unique about the industry it's
like it's really you know Innovative and
people we're the Risk Takers we're the
first adopters a lot of these things
that you know the big Tech or the VCS
like they're not touching it yet because
they want to see how it plays out so
that's what's new think about our
industry it's like you know we're risk
adverse and we are willing to take those
steps Brandy how long have you been in
the porn industry 19 years okay what is
there like uh in the NFL it's like three
years is the average life what is it
that in uh in the porn issue do you know
oh I in general I don't know I kind of
like to think of myself as Tom Brady
I might retire once or twice and come
back on the field you never know you
never know man this panel is exactly
what I was hoping for
and talk a little bit I think when we
think of business right how has it
evolved over those 20 years or so from
like maybe when you started to now oh
it's definitely evolved again as early
adopters of a lot of Technology it's
constantly changing we've taught every
everyone I've listened to today has
talked about the bell curve we go
through the thing the same ebb and flow
whether it's new entertainment whether
it's VR whether it's
um there's so many things that are
constantly changing it so every two to
three years I feel like I'm in a new
industry there's always an opportunity
for whether personal reinvention or to
learn A New Concept I don't know about
you guys but when VR came out
it was like what is this new thing and
now it's oh it's a VR day no no big deal
and regarding the financial and business
aspect of it I personally came into the
adult industry
career-minded I didn't plan on sticking
my toe in the pool I I dove head first
and said if I'm going to do this I'm
going to treat it like any other career
and put together a performa in a three
five seven year and followed it and I
believe that's probably everyone on this
panel treated their career as such not
just as a thing I'm going to do for a
year or two and see where it goes we all
took it quite seriously like you would
any profession Lisa what is kind of your
experience on the business I've been a
30-year industry
yeah yes
an industry veteran I watched it go from
VHS film
DVD internet I saw every cycle early at
18 years old started to research the
industry and realized one thing this is
the most recession-proofed option that's
going to allow me the Financial Freedom
too
uh do this as long as I want to and
there's so many different ways to make
money as a performer when it comes to I
still travel globally to host events and
to just do signings it doesn't go away
it's not time sensitive there's a new
fan every day that doesn't know whether
you did this yesterday or 10 years ago
and I just wanted to Parlay that life
into the freedom as now I'm 50 years old
being able to work moderately but not
have to do a lot of things because I
financially set myself up for the long
term
Eva so where am I again
by the way they told me that they're
more nervous because they have clothes
on than not which was a huge issue
backstage so we're good to go yeah a
little wardrobe malfunction but we're
good
um so I've been in the industry for
about 12 years and I don't think I
initially went in with the same like
performa and I'm going to take this
super serious it was more of like this
is where I belong and I'll figure it out
I think what I realized after very soon
after entering the industry is you kind
of are forced to evolve as a person
because so many people don't accept that
decision so because of the lifespan
which is about an hour or an hour in
some cases a year for some performers
um
a year is the typical career span for
someone entering the industry so you do
this Unthinkable thing that people don't
want to accept it's like what do you do
after because you closed 90 of doors
like you can't go be a first first
responder a teacher like essentially you
have to invest in your yourself so I
think once I realized that it's like
this money is okay it's certainly not
great and it's not going to be here
forever so what do you do after the fact
yeah Lisa last night we were talking and
um the CEO of Cameo is going to be on a
panel later today uh and you said that
one of the interesting aspects of being
a performer having notoriety is it
doesn't give you the excuse to just oh
money will flow in because people know
who I am you still have to have that
entrepreneurial mindset and one of the
things that you've done is you've used
Cameo to basically host a fantasy
football drafts
so I actually use it to pull the draft
and they'll send me another 12 teams
I'll go in the DM who one last year
what's your last place and I will do
anywhere from 20 to 25 of these
recordings a day for the entire month of
August it owns my life also so you know
since I retired I do sports radio
Fantasy Football sports betting all this
so it kind of really ties in I brought
my mail fan base from the adult industry
into following me doing sports radio
since 2013. so it is a lot of people
have listened but the draft order thing
is so nuts it is so much work there are
eight to ten minute videos which we know
cameos are usually like two minutes but
I put my heart and soul into it because
I love a good fantasy football draft and
I love the smack talk I love to give
tips for the first round who I think
you're going to take at that spot and
it's just given me a connection with
fans remember these men and women that
have watched me for years they've also
grown up with me you know getting in in
the early 90s and now they're watching
my new life and they're like you know
this is really cool like we watched you
and now we're here with you doing this
and there's no reason to feel like you
have to hide and Escape once you own it
and you're like how do I transfer this
ownership of this into my next thing
while still having a ton of Pride for
the fact that I had such a great career
in the industry yeah that's amazing uh
Spencer you started a business uh
recently that tries to take your
experience and success in the porn
industry but also think of consumer
products talk a little bit about like
starting a business how to how do you
look at the advantages and disadvantages
to having been in the porn industry but
like now translating it into being an
executive although the product still
touches yeah for me my my journey has
kind of come full circle I'll let the
crowd know that you and I were roommates
uh 10 years ago in North Carolina we
were in the same Tech incubator so one
day he literally shows up in the living
room and he's like hey man I'm moving
out
where are you going La what are you
gonna go do there I'm gonna go break
into the porn industry it's like sure
dude what are you really going for and
here we are yeah so um so it's funny
it's things come full circle um at the
time I was a startup Tech entrepreneur
uh started a live streaming app in the
hospitality space and um I started using
porn and webcaming to help fund my
startup so you know I was able to learn
the business side and kind of how to you
know really just survive I used my you
know sometimes you got to take that risk
and at that point in my life you know I
was working three jobs I was paying
developers to build my app over 100 an
hour this was 2012 when you know there's
only a couple app developers out there
so it was about survival and resilience
and I did end up moving out to
California and you know I've always been
an entrepreneur and you know being able
to leverage you know my connections with
the adult industry like they said you
know it's really helped me develop
businesses
um currently I'm a co-founder of a
condom company the fastest growing
condom company in the US called PS
condoms on the same note Brandy's one of
our investors
so she believed in us early on and we're
doing pretty well and it's so like in
this business specifically
what are the things that you can do from
like a business perspective that helps
make it become one of the fastest
growing Quantum companies because I
think a lot of people be like oh if
you're in the porn industry then you can
turn around and just like tell a bunch
of people to use it but like that so
with that it translates I look at us as
the professional athletes of sex so for
example if you're a pro football player
you endorse you know gloves or cleats
like that's our endorsement like we you
know we should be the ones speaking
about safe sex and sexual health because
they're obviously doing a terrible job
teaching it in school I tell people the
last place where you want to learn about
sex and sexual health is watching porn
because it's basically at the end of the
day it's a movie it's not real life so
people try to go to watch porn to learn
about sex and sex ed and all that so you
know we have the position to be that
voice and to you know leverage our
connections and our experience about
sexual health to really you know whether
to sell a product or team educate people
because uh you know STD is a real thing
pregnancies on one and pregnancy is a
real thing so these are real world
issues you know we're helping curve so
Eva you've got a podcast you've started
to push really far into kind of the
content world and build out a lot of
stuff on social media how did you think
about the transition and like how much
of what you'd done previously helped
versus you mentioned earlier being boxed
out from certain industries or jobs did
it hurt at all
when I launched the podcast so like when
I initially launched it charted right
away which I think a lot of people can't
do where it would hurt is I mean I
introduced my real name so it's called
chatting with Candace and I was like I'm
Candace who are back and everyone's like
oh my God what did she do like now she's
putting herself in danger all of these
things we tell ourselves but you could
have always have Googled it before for
me it was really important to create the
distinction between Eva and Candace
because I really wanted to drive home
like kind of like you were just saying
is that porn is entertainment so like
you're not gonna see me
um and like automatically think oh she
is only this one thing she's only good
for one thing so I wanted to show like
the real me and I can't have like a
neuroscientist on the podcast and have
him call me my porn name like that's
just ridiculous to me so like I have to
I have to be brave and just put the real
me out there otherwise no one is going
to take me seriously and that's already
such an uphill battle so I was just
trying to make it easier on myself
um and I'm glad I did it but now it's
like the anonymity is gone so that's
something I'm still trying to navigate
as a mom now so it's like when is that
shoe going to drop because I have two
Littles
um but yeah I think if you see Matt
Damon you don't automatically start like
a knife fight with him in the street
you're like that's Jason Bourne right
like you can you can separate the two
but for some reason with us like you
can't separate it it's like you are just
like this sexual being and you're not
allowed to be intelligent for some
reason it's like if you're expressing
yourself sexually and very openly you
must be taking it from some other bucket
and that must be your self-worth or that
must be your intelligence it's not that
case right like we're almost
multifaceted it's like we're just more
comfortable on the outskirts and kind of
showing that vulnerability how do you
balance
um I'll use like the industry name
almost as like a Alter Ego right like to
some degree it's like you have your real
identity of your real name you're in an
interesting spot because you are using
both to some degree right like when we
were promoting the event I would see a
tweet go out under your real name and
then I I'd see one go out under the
industry name and I was like oh I forget
that like you have those two different
identities how have you found success in
balancing those two because you don't
want to necessarily alienate or give up
the audience that you had but you kind
of want to expand into these new areas I
look at it like atop a funnel so I
started the podcast as like a form of
contribution and that might sound kind
of lame but I feel like a lot of people
online it's very take take take take and
it's not providing anything back to your
audience so for me I felt a
responsibility especially during like
the crazy political times of like 2020
and even to today to offer a third
perspective right we're in a place where
everyone is like so divisive and so
black and white thinking especially when
it comes to something like sex or
politics or anything like that so just
like offering a third rail and what does
that look like
um so I'll still have like my adult
content on Eva but I'm always trying to
push people to the canvas content
because like there is more and look
there's more in you and there's more in
me and just kind of that's the ethos of
everything and then Candace is like this
more pure pristine character and she's
not she does not exist in the adult
space so that does not cross over but
there's like a little bit of it's um
like a Venn diagram I mean just trying
to like pull a little bit so Candace Eva
pomp Anthony got it yeah all right
Brandy you have a bunch of things that
you've done completely outside in terms
of real estate uh real estate
development you have bought vacation
properties built an entire business
there talk a little bit about uh
something that you've done for 20 years
that most people if you walk down the
street would know you for but in the
background you're like building a
completely different business is there
issues and challenges there and like how
have you used the experience that you
had in the industry for the benefit of
actually building out on the real estate
side well to Candace's Point
um nobody knows my real name other than
my great-grandfather my maiden name but
my face is Brandi Love they're they're
they go side by side so regardless of
what I call myself
publicly it's Brandy so there have been
times in our real estate business where
we go to purchase a home because we we
do both Renovations and vacation rentals
but there's always a renovation involved
in the process
we buy the home or put in a contract and
we're excited it's perfect house we've
already started to develop its concept
what we want it to look like
and our realtor will come back and go
guys I don't know how to tell you this
but they won't sell you the house
because we were Googled and they don't
care for my other profession first time
it happened it was a little like I
wanted to dig my heels in and fight you
know because that just feels so wrong
it's just it is wrong and then you
realize you know what
I I chose a profession that is
controversial not everybody is capable
of managing it in their own minds it's
going to happen and in the course of 10
years that we've had the real estate
business we've lost
two homes to purchase and we ended up
selling a vacation home because the
neighbors made it such hell they made it
very clear that they were going to ruin
our guests time and that they were going
to make every part of the process from
renovation to leasing in impossibility I
used to get ulcers driving down the
street it was so uncomfortable so you
just you cut your it wasn't a loss it
was still we still sold it for a profit
so that was good but you you need to
know when to just walk away and that has
to do with choices that we made to be in
the adult industry industry which
I have zero um
regrets regarding it however there you
have to know that there are going to be
some challenges or roadblocks from
people who don't want to accept that you
could be more than or
um you know guests that show up and you
you any questions you know here's the
TVs here's the AC and one of the members
of the family is going
and and you just kind of look at them
you're like
keep moving keep moving you know you
don't call them on it no no do you know
how many people in the audience
privately messaged me it was like I
don't know who these people
it's cool it's totally cool but
um the the business aspect I I think
somewhat through DNA for my great
grandfather my grandfather my father all
very brilliant business people the
entrepreneurial spirit I was born with
it thank God my husband of 28 years has
the same zest for life and business and
his professional career with my
professional career pre-adult it created
the career for the adult world and then
we just parlayed that into real estate
and there was a learning curve neither
one of us came from Real Estate or
interior designing or any of that so the
first three years were a huge um
learning curve and we made every mistake
you can make and
um now we just love it it's just part of
who we are it's amazing Lisa you have
books that you've written which uh you
were fortunate or I guess I was
fortunate enough that you sent to me and
as I was reading through them
um it was very clear that like you cared
and the books came and there was even
you know personalized uh notes and like
all these things that
um I think most people would assign to
like oh that's the work of an executive
who understands how to play a game of
relationships and long-term thinking and
like all this stuff
not necessarily I think what people
would expect if you're like hey let me
send you my book
where does that come from and then like
why books as one of the many things that
you're doing uh as an Avenue to kind of
build these alternative Revenue sources
for yourself
limited television channels and hotels
so other than going to sporting events I
would sneak into every single conference
where there was a speaking engagement so
I get to the holiday and it had the
Jinky thing with the letters that popped
in of who's there and I'd scope out
what's going and so I would stay in on
these I travel alone I would take the
book I would read it and so that was my
entire 20s was just living that life in
hotels going to all these shows and it
really made me think about how I'm
operating with my customers you know we
have direct access to our customers
whether it be at a club whether it be a
direct message on a platform whether it
be on social media you are getting
customer feedback all the time and so I
took what I gathered from the smartest
people that I got to listen to and what
I saw from the people that I was meeting
and having these interactions with was
putting these two things together
is so fulfilling because you're
surprising people always people think of
the lowest common denominator when they
think of people in the industry their
expectations are so low that you can
always over deliver and as you find joy
in that you even put more passion in the
writing was really just another way for
me to tell my story
um I've always been a writer I want a
creative writing contest in Pennsylvania
fifth grade
take that fifth graders in Pennsylvania
I was on the cover of my local newspaper
and it was my first taste of Fame
[Music]
and it's a passion of mine I love to
read so I thought well this is another
way for me to travel the country and do
events do signings network with authors
I self-publish I like the whole process
of owning and selling my books myself
getting them out to Amazon and selling
to them I will not do their printing
services where they print on demand it
burdens me that they're going to slowly
put out all of the printers I have a
storage place in Minneapolis they
distribute for me so I like that I'm
adding to the economy by having
businesses that rely on other people to
have jobs to help me fulfill those
businesses and so it just keeps me
always growing in different directions
the niche of fantasy sports and sports
betting though it's growing it alienates
a lot of my fan base that might not be
into sports they're the there comes the
podcast there comes the books so just
keeping my voice out there to so many
different groups of people allows me to
stay relevant and for most performers
there's a stage name I use my real name
you know in the 90s we thought this was
VHS they're gonna all break nobody's
gonna know who we are there's no
internet yet nobody recognizes us
anywhere because it's so much hair and
makeup back then and everyone used their
real name and it's a strange thing
because I get both perspectives
but this has been my whole life and it
really truly is who I am and I'm so glad
that Lisa Ann is just one person I don't
think I could manage two and because I
do get recognized everywhere it would be
real like oh hi Trixie it's like no I'm
at the airport my name's Lisa Ann you
know it's it's the same but writing has
been a great outlet for me to challenge
myself as well because it takes patience
uh it takes time and it really makes you
dig deep and I wanted the first book
shares my experience of getting into the
business and getting out of the business
my second book shares the experience of
how I've evolved since I left the
business what I've learned how I
probably appreciate business now more
than I did when I was in it and how
there's so many traps and I was very
lucky to never be driven towards a trap
in the business if it becomes a
lifestyle instead of you creating your
future lifestyle it's a problem explain
that because I think one of one of the
things through my private conversations
with each of you and also a couple of
comments you made here is this idea that
like this was a stepping stone to
Capital which then allowed for building
businesses or investment portfolios when
you say that it could have become a
lifestyle but instead it was for your
future lifestyle what do you mean by
that well you know it's a social
lifestyle a lot of celebrities will
reach out athletes will reach out you
can just be going going going seeing
people doing things the drugs are
present
uh and that's toxic alcohol any any sort
of a trap if someone is just on the edge
it is not a business for somebody that
doesn't have a strong mind
there's traps when it comes to spending
I mean you'll see I I had an agency for
four years in the industry it was the
absolute worst job I ever had
um bail bondsman's call in the middle of
the night girl wants a check at two
o'clock in the morning she's gonna tweak
out and go to a check cashing store and
I would see girls that couldn't pay a 10
commission but they had twenty thousand
dollars on their person from their shoes
their purse their sunglasses and so I
would say to them this business isn't
for you it's a lifestyle to you and it's
going to ruin your life it has to be a
future lifestyle that you're creating by
Saving investing learning you know and
planning for what will you do when you
are like you said 90 of the workforce is
not hiring you uh and when you are in
that Workforce when I first started
working for SiriusXM I remember the
anxiety I had my first year of meeting
people and thinking like what do these
people think about me and I realize that
people are human and it's how you
present yourself and you can change
someone's mind and open the perspective
yeah it's the reason why I thought uh
thinking of this panel specifically is
reinvention right and something that you
guys all have had to constantly do both
in the industry but also outside of the
industry uh even one of the things that
uh most people who have a company or
Founders and tech companies would talk
about is like customer feedback
um you ain't got to go far in the
industry to get some sort of feedback
how did you think about what feedback to
listen to and what feedback you could
ignore right because if you get on
Twitter or you get on Instagram or
something I'm sure people are going to
say all kinds of crazy stuff from I love
you to I hate you you know all the
different things but then there's also
like industry specific there's porn
sites there's probably direct uh um
emails that you're getting like all this
information how did you sift through it
and know like this is worth listening to
and this isn't so I try not to read the
comments too much because it can be very
overwhelming people are not you guys
take that to a whole other level
I try to think of myself in a situation
where maybe I was disappointed in a
business experience or some kind of
transaction and how I would show up in
that experience so if I'm trying to like
offer honest feedback back for a
restaurant and in hopes that they do
better I'm going to present that in a
certain way if I'm trying to like burn
that restaurant down to the ground on
Yelp and like leave five pages of why my
chicken wings were not right like that's
maybe not something to listen to like
that's not a healthy that's not a
healthy form of feedback so I think you
can really quickly gauge is this person
like trying to help me you know maybe
fix a shortcoming or like do better or
are they just like out for blood and you
have to be able to accept that very
quickly and not take it personal which
is um ever you're trying to ever evolve
to that point because some days you're
like I've got this I can read any
comment and you know it's not going to
phase me and then other days you'll be
crying like why is this happening yeah
um so yeah just try to be mindful of
that
how's it to be a guy in the industry God
bless you ladies because I see what you
guys get in the inboxes of the DMs like
all the comments us guys we have way
easier so like I bow down to you what do
you deal with with your fans and the
haters and whoever
um for me like I Look to You Know pro
athletes kind of how they handle
themselves you know because they have a
bad game they're getting blown up on not
only national television on the sports
channels but their Twitter their DMS
their family their cousins everyone's
getting like hey you suck like so it's
you can't you go Overlook that stuff
it's it's mental toughness it's kind of
just overlooking it because at the end
of the day these people they don't know
who you are they don't know what you're
going through maybe you had a bad game
because you had an injury you know it's
just there's so many different factors
to it
and it's it can be tough and like I know
a lot of my peers like they'll get
bogged down by these comments but
there's just some like it's it's
internet trolls and it's it's uh it's
just what it is with the internet
um pre-internet there wasn't really were
you guys getting mail
yeah I did a fan club
[Laughter]
I guess I did I sold stuff Lisa and
pioneered the newsletter business
I am old okay
Brandy one of the things that most
people in the tech industry is aware of
is only fans and they've at least read a
headline about it
um and we're talking backstage about
this idea that like there are now
subscription businesses that are popping
up around newsletters podcasts like that
has very much become a thing as a a
business model only fans didn't
necessarily start out for adult industry
uh members but uh I think as you said
like once you guys took over that real
estate only fans became a much more
successful business like how has that
shaped the decision making that people
have in the industry like are people
saying hey look maybe I actually don't
need to go and and you know participate
in these shoots or do these videos
because I can go direct to the fans or
like what's happened there maybe I may
have an interesting perspective or
different
um
I do both again I still go out to LA and
I shoot the pro scenes for multiple
reasons one I still love it and uh two
I'm not ready to walk off the field it I
also still am enjoying it's the craziest
time to be
um our age that's why you watch yourself
when you talk about being old
um
to be a woman our age at this time is
unbelievable I feel like with every year
I get older I get more popular which is
insanity because when I first started in
the industry like if you were in your
20s you're you're hot you're you're 18
babe you get in in your 30s and they're
kind of like what do we do with her what
is she there wasn't a word yet
um and even older than that there there
wasn't really anybody there were a few
that were pioneering the way but it
wasn't a genre and now like MILF it's
hilarious because there's so kind of few
of us that you can be 24 in your milk
get back in your category but it's um
you guys know what I'm talking about
um it is a really awesome time to be
doing and be involved in the adult
industry at my age the difference with
the only fans is obviously the content
creator owns their content when we go to
La you you shoot your scene you're
handed your check and you say goodbye to
everything you did that day right you
don't own it
um and fans will ask when is the scene
coming out I I don't know I don't get
that information I find out when you
find out whereas on only fans your the
daily conversations the the private DMS
which can go a million different
directions the custom content that
you're creating for the individual fan
plus the weekly content that you're
dropping two three times a week that is
your own content that you created either
by yourself or with other
um industry Talent so I find that
multiple revenue streams are always
welcome and this time in the adult
industry and in non-adult there's rock
stars and chefs and artists that are on
only fans utilizing this Revenue stream
so
oh
I find there's great uh benefit to doing
both for me right now got it and Lisa I
think you were telling me that uh
there's chat functionality on some of
these that you've used with great
success can you explain a little bit as
like what what is going on there from
the Creator standpoint
uh so we do you can set up your only
fans direct message to charge per text
you can go back and forth you can sell
things through the direct message so I
use the platform still to this day even
though I don't shoot new content
I use it as a library for everything
that I own because I owned my own
content for about 15 years before I
retired I had a production company
and when the tube sites really started
to to show in say 2006 2007 a lot of
companies were going under and so I went
to those companies door-to-door was like
hey can I buy back all my scenes with
the paperwork so I took everything off
the shelves that was just going to be
done I won't chat for free on weekends
so I set up a thing every Saturday
morning I do a voice note group like hey
it's the weekend we should all be
getting out this is when you should go
out and meet somebody I'm trying to
really bring that like have
conversations with women because there's
a lot of just really lonely men in there
but I still do get messages and they
will pay me to respond on the weekends
so I look at like hey if I can make an
extra 500 a thousand dollars Saturdays
and Sundays just by responding the
messages because I forced the I don't
sext I don't uh have personal
conversations I keep a very
strict kind of rules of like hey I don't
want to form a relationship with you
that is dishonest and I felt that very
young when I was dancing and I was a
house girl I felt there was a game of
manipulation with the industry that I
didn't want to lean into and that's why
I started to do porn because I wanted to
feature dance I wanted to go on the road
be a limited time offer where I'm in
each club for a week a weekend I make a
ton of money I leave I don't have to do
that mind game and so I'm the same with
my direct messages there I use the Cameo
direct messages to get closer with my
buyers so any any platform that has a
direct message feature is really you you
need to utilize it because utilizing it
is building that Bond somebody sees
their message oh my gosh she messaged me
it's such a big deal to them and I would
say I probably put about
two hours a day into messaging back on
all of my platforms and when you talked
about comments
the most important thing I ever did was
hire somebody which I still have that
just deletes negative comments for me
and so when my stuff gets posted on
YouTube and we have stuff going out
podcasts what have you she'll give me a
clearance time we're like all right the
streets are clean because we call it
cleaning the streets she's like all
right the streets are clean you can go
and then it only allows me to engage
with my positive interactions it's not
that I don't want the negative feedback
I just know the toll that it paid on me
the first 10 years I allowed it in my
brain and I was like this isn't making
me grow this isn't making me better this
isn't helping me succeed I don't want to
feed in I don't want to clap back I
don't want to waste time so I have
someone that does that and it's a game
changer when it comes and with only fans
you can block people's messages there's
certain words they can't send you
there's certain words you can't send
them so I just keep that as something
that like it's a tool only two hours a
day will I do it but it's a tool what I
find interesting is many people here who
know me or have listened to a lot of the
content I'm obsessed with like the early
2000s late 90s rappers I think that they
ended up being some of the best
entrepreneurs in the world right people
are laughing but like they're all
billionaires and we're not so
all right like they did something right
um but there was this theme I think that
they really learned which was like own
the Masters to their music uh own the
company stop promoting all these other
brands and products and I recently read
a book about Zach Greenberg about Jay-Z
and how there was literally controversy
he would mention an alcohol brand and
then reporters would spend literally
months trying to figure out does he have
a business relationship or not and after
years of doing this they eventually
concluded like this dude ain't mentioned
in anything unless he owns a piece
somewhere it may be in the company it
may be in the distributor admit like he
is very very calculated where did that
come from like why did you think to do
that in terms of like buying back some
of the videos or having a production
company or doing it so I was always just
incredibly invested on knowing that I've
seen so much change from shooting on
film from going to digital from going
only fans wasn't a thing yet but I had a
website so I was like any content I can
buy back I can recycle on my website so
I just constantly wanted to continue to
grow that and grow that and grow that
and again this is not time sensitive
content I'm making more money off of my
library and only fans now than I was
making when I was shooting in the
business which is just crazy and it's
free money it takes me an hour a day I
do it myself I upload the photos then
they get the video a little teaser for
the next day and it's just something
that I I said this is what I'm gonna do
I'm going to buy everything back I want
to own as much of my stuff that's out
there as possible and continue to resell
it
either how do you think about social
media like today as you build these
other businesses social media for most
people in here is the marketing channel
right whether it's from a podcast for a
small business whatever how have you
taken maybe some of the things that you
learned in the industry and then said
hey I want to do the same exact
mechanism I want to use you know where I
learned how to post certain types of
videos or photos or whatever but now the
content is going to be different but
it's the same kind of vessel on the same
platform I think the overarching theme
is just connection so it's just like
seeing what people are looking for and
when it comes to only fans I think
that's where 99 of my Revenue comes from
it's not from like a video or a picture
it's from trying to connect with people
and I think even when you see like going
back to like the negative comments
that's all it is it's attention seeking
Behavior because they are not getting it
from somewhere else so if you can kind
of you learn how to Captivate your
members and be present with them I think
that's going to be the best for your
business model and I actually love what
you were doing about saying like it's
the weekend go out and not have this
unethical relationship with your fans so
I think that's one of the things that I
like too about having both versions of
myself out there on social it's like I'm
not I'm not pretending I'm single like
I'm very open that I'm married and I
have two kids
um and and I share that side of my life
as well so if I'm participating in like
a sexting thing like we're both under
we're both aware and like consenting
that that's what it is you know what I
mean it is entertainment it's fantasy
like this is not real and like go out
and meet a real girl like go have a real
conversation find a hobby you know
invest in yourself too like I think
there's this idea that porn is bad in
general but it's a tool like anything
else so if you're over consuming
anything it's going to be problematic
just like social media so use it like a
tool and don't let that tool use you and
then you know best practices yeah I
think it makes a ton of sense Spencer as
you raised money obviously Brandy
invested but I'm assuming you talk to
other investors what was their reaction
and like were they oh this product has
like audience fit right A lot of people
talking about product Market fit yeah
they may talk about founder market fit
but a lot of times in this Creator
economy there's this idea of like does
this product fit this audience and I
recently had a conversation with
somebody uh who came on as the president
of a very large organization that
targets kind of 20 to 30 year old men
and they actually tried two or three
different products
okay success and they launched an
alcohol and it exploded and so his
lesson was like you got to find the
right product for the Right audience
yeah condoms given your following from
the industry it's like a pretty good
Product Industry fit or product audience
fit did investors get that
they did because we called the big three
condoms Trojan directs and Lifestyles
your grandfather's condoms each of those
brands have literally been around for
over 100 years so it's like they've been
around for so long you know that's what
the past Generations they're used to so
there hadn't been any innovation in the
space it had gone pretty stagnant so we
saw that opportunity and kind of
relaying that idea to our investors
we're like oh [__] this is actually a
good idea and our motivation for our
inspiration for the concept because even
when my business partners came to me my
co-founders they're like military
company I looked at was like are you
[__] seriously I don't want to
[__] start a cotton company because
so when we uh we do our shoots we're
tested very rigorously every 10 to 14
days so we don't use condoms in our
scene so I was like well I'm not using
them for work so how could I really
portray this and they're like well look
at it as the pro athlete perspective you
know I can be that person to tell the
benefits of the condoms
um
so yeah it was uh when you go through
all of that and you're talking to the
audience it I think very obviously the
three uh women have a audience that most
people probably think is the general
audience right it's like guys who are
messaging you who are consuming the
content who are doing this stuff
um you're talking to them but also
there's this like hey get out in the
real world like you know this is not
real life who's your audience who's my
audience specifically well just like
like when you think of the audience is
it mostly females is it like kind of
what I would consider ancillary audience
to like what Their audience is so for me
personally um I I've been shooting a lot
the past couple years for this company
called Belleza um but less is actually
the top adult site for women in the
world
um so in the past few years there's been
a really a movement into like the
romance porn like real life you know
real sex because a lot of the adult
films that we've shot in our careers is
like the really cheesy you know like
funny faces like obviously the
stepmoms that like the different
Dynamics you know so it's there's been a
Advent of real life sex
um so you know my demographic has
changed from like frat Bros to you know
women so that's been a good change for
me
um
the guys asked like crazy things says
you know it's it's a different thing
guys ask crazy things yeah they're like
all right you're asking me sex tips and
stuff like that women are you know a
little more respectable
Brandy you still shoot professionally
how do you think about why to do that is
there like a economic calculation of
like I'll do it if I get paid X versus
not do it is it just like I literally
want to be Tom Brady of porn like what
goes into deciding like when will when
will you stop and I think of it from the
perspective of like there's cash being
generated there right and you're able to
use that cash to fund other things that
you're doing and so that there's as much
of like a personal decision as a
business decision if you want to stop
doing it it's both personal and
Financial in the sense that again I'm
not ready to retire I'm still learning
about myself and for me personally
growing I can't tell you how much I've
grown individually
learning about myself through the adult
industry like people say all the time
like do you have any fantasies you
haven't done yet well yeah of course if
if they were all succeeded if I'd done
everything I'd probably retire it's part
of the process I I believe I'll know I
have I still have a set of goals things
that I want to do that I haven't done
yet those are going to happen
and I I feel like at this 19 years I'm
I'm kind of writing the the top of the
bell curve and there's no way I'm
leaving while I'm there things have
finally gotten really good I'm truly
enjoying who I am in the industry
um as well as being able to Parlay uh
the financial aspect into our other many
endeavors
so I'm just to be totally honest I'm
having way too much fun and I'm not
ready to walk away yet yeah
it's interesting because if you talk to
a lot of tech Founders specifically like
the whole idea of like uh you'll never
have more fun than when you're winning
right I think kind of from a degree each
one of you at certain points in your
career in the industry like you were the
winner right you were winning and so
it's hard to know when to walk away but
also I wonder younger people people who
are just starting out now in that
industry do they see oh wait I should
build these other businesses I should
build these other revenue streams so
like it's easier to walk away in the
future or is that just come with
experience and maturity either you can
speak to it
I like to be optimistic but
I often found myself being the only one
in the room that is trying to like teach
other younger performers about simple
things like taxes or how to incorporate
or thinking of the future because when
they get in so young and this is
something I'm really public about is
like raising the age of Entry because I
think that 18 is you're not ready you
are just not ready to make that decision
at 18 that when you get in so young you
actually leave worse off than before
because they weren't prepared for the
future
um so so yeah I I think it's good that
we're leading by example but I don't
think that it's adopted at massia and I
think that that's kind of why we all
share our stories for me I stopped
shooting in the mainstream industry
probably like seven years ago just
simply because like some of my
principles are like ultimate Freedom
ownership and I wasn't getting that I
was a contract star so I mean talk about
not owning anything like they think they
own your name in some cases so I just
had too many bad experiences where I
wasn't like modeling the behavior of my
values and then that's why I left
because I'm like I value ownership I
value Creator Forward Thinking
um we started an agency about like two
and a half years ago that helps creators
with their only fans accounts and the
thing there is like you just see for
some reason there's like almost like
this Mass hypnosis that these agencies
and companies have done to these younger
performers where they think that their
value is tied to something else and not
owned by themselves so we're trying to
like just within our own ecosystem kind
of take out those bad ideas and instill
confidence and like forward-minded
thinking like what are you going to do
with this money in the future right
because it's going to go away and maybe
not with AI right we see chat gbt and Ai
and maybe you can live forever as like
30 or 40 or 50 or whatever you choose
but just to think like how can you
create this as a stepping stone and not
like this is your end goal
Lisa when you think about what you've
done so far how much of what's happening
in this like Creator economy is
replicable by somebody like you right so
when I think of the Creator economy we
see Mr bees too has all this content out
there uh he's not an important industry
but yeah yeah but he he holds people's
attention right and somebody once told
me one of the big misconceptions in
content is that people think I'm putting
up a YouTube video in a specific
category and my YouTube videos competing
with the other person in that category
but no your YouTube video is competing
with Spotify is competing with
television is competing with a Kindle
like all these Technologies are
competing for attention and so if you
get attention people are realizing
launch products launch businesses right
um you're doing a lot of different
things kind of tangential can you go and
build an entire business and kind of use
yourself as the face like a Mr B system
or how have you thought about that I
think I already have I look at the life
that I'm living right now what I've
created is just solely from me and all
of the different Avenues I have about 12
main streams of income that are all
completely different businesses and they
all rely on me so I'm completely
engaging using every platform using my
brand name and speaking and I think the
most unique thing I get back you know I
got to speak at the Oxford Union about
the age of porn and also not using it as
education in schools and so what I've
learned from people is their most fast
fascinated when they see one of us have
a good conversation and that we're good
speakers and that we're present and so
they've only viewed you one way from
that link that they saw on that tube
site that's their first impression first
impressions mean a lot I get that takes
us a little bit longer to pave that way
but now that I'm there I quite often
will say to myself like I just can't
believe you've done all of this from
like starting at a strip club at a GoPro
bar like this is wild and it's
constantly coming to me faster and
faster when it comes to being brought
into different countries for for events
and going in and doing sports things
going to the draft going to the Super
Bowl all the different betting aspects
of people buying posts from me like hey
we just need one post what's going to
cost that's a business
um social media has become such a stream
of income for me it still blows my mind
so I do think it's possible I think The
Branding is the most important part and
staying true to who you've been from the
jump I grew a lot in the industry the
industry taught me who I was uh really
showed me a lot about myself what I do
and don't like but here I am just my own
business who can get involved in
anything just using my brand name yeah
it's amazing
um to finish up I'd love to go just one
by one and talk about the team that you
have that you operate with
um and also it as much as you're willing
to share in terms of like how you think
about uh monitoring your financials so
we had Cody Sanchez up here earlier
she's like hey every Friday I basically
sit down I go through all the P L's of
all my businesses or whatever so like
what team do you operate with in your
various businesses and then how do you
think about actually measuring those
platforms do you have like a CFO is it
all through like a QuickBooks are you
the platforms just reporting it to you
however you think about that yeah for me
as Cody said earlier the team is
everything it's it's hard to come across
a good team but fortunately enough for
you know my situation with PS our team
is solid um you know two of my
co-founders went to Wharton Goldman
Sachs so you know they're rock stars on
the finance side and kind of structuring
business so we can ultimately exit it
myself being a marketing mind you know
we really complement each other our
creatives like it's four co-founders so
we all have very diverse functions but
we're all really good at what we do so
having a diverse team is really
important and having a team that really
you know allows you to believe in
yourself and each other like I always
know that my partner or my teammate has
my back so that's the biggest thing is
having the trust with your teammates and
knowing that they're going to do their
job it's it's a team effort at the end
of the day
Brandy
um my team is very small it's my husband
and I uh we have tried to venture out
more than once and again to Cody's Point
she was she was phenomenal I took notes
you you do need a team of people around
you uh the adult space is extremely
difficult to bring people in because
it's so very personal
um I I find it harder to allow people
into that Circle to help you manage
anything because
again our work is our lives I am who I
am my personality is the same as as the
brand so Chris and I do absolutely
everything
um together so I'm hiring
there's some really great minds in this
room man what an amazing opportunity I
went to Palms conference and I got a job
and Brandi Love It Could Happen and I
don't eat it a dollar and I donated a
dollar to the back
so so to be totally honest though we we
are always seeking and there it is
always important to try to find those
those great people who will have your
back and bring a different
aspect of different business trait a
different mindset into the business to
help it grow because if you don't it it
will we've been very successful we're
very happy but we're also entrepreneurs
and are going to continue to want to
grow and to do so we're going to have to
expand our our team it makes sense Lisa
what about you
um my team's divided into two sections
here so I have the team that's
definitely smarter than me uh that would
be my business manager who does all of
my mail all of my books all of my
billing invoicing agent and my my wealth
manager so there's that team is we check
in weekly when it comes to my money I'm
looking at my money weekly
um my Corp of course pays me as an
employee so I'm going through that
quarterly that is really well handled by
somebody that's way smarter than me
because I'm a Creator and I want to be
creative and I don't want to be bogged
down with mail so that's an expense
worth having and also really keeps me
structured because they're so tight with
each other that it's always inspired me
to pushing me to save more take this
game do this we're doing this we're
going to invest this and this then I
have 10. I manage a team of ten all
women
and they do everything with me from
content creation editing social media
assistant work like that's my team so I
I do have a nice robust group and I like
to know that I'm helping other people be
fed that's really important to me I love
making sure other people are fed that
they're paid well that their invoice is
responded to immediately young women
especially creators and editors have
come to me and said like it's really
weird being an independent contractor as
a woman because men will get paid first
like if a business is doing their
billing they'll be like Oh I'm gonna pay
this guy whereas women will be last so
I've always brought my team to be a
female based team and they know through
me they'll get a lot of other gigs
through other people but it's nice to
have a team that I that knows my voice
they'll see something on social media
and immediately text me like hey don't
look at social media right now let me
tap these things taken down let me do
this they buffer things that could
distract me and I want to avoid
distractors so I have a pretty big team
that's amazing evil racer It's
relatively small especially compared to
that I call my husband the master of
coin
Game of Thrones so he does most of our
investing I think the thing that we
collaborate when it comes to that is we
only invest in companies that we believe
in their mission so we don't just like
bet on a sure thing so where our money
goes I think is really important as far
as the agency goes it's like finding the
thing that you want and knowing your own
weak spots like I [__] hate
spreadsheets I hate Sops we have weekly
calls and he's like okay Candace I know
that you're gonna hate this but I have
this sop I'm like okay Jake just tell me
about it so I'm caught up and I'm up to
speed so finding your weak points and
finding someone who like thrives in that
area so our CEO of the agency like
drives in chaos and he loves a good
spreadsheet so he is perfect for that
job every Wednesday we go through all of
the accounts that we help manage my
account specifically and how the agency
is doing and um you know as we bring on
new creators what that looks like my
husband tries not to tell me too much
because we have a lot in crypto so he'll
tell me when it's a good day and then
the rest he's just kind of quiet and
I'll just like look through the memes
and I just know where we're at so like
it's okay we have a plan and we're just
we're gonna hold so that's where we're
at
um yeah I'm like I'm I'm more of the
Visionary but when it comes to the
crypto again it's it's investing in what
you believe in which is like sovereignty
and freedom and being sensor proof and
all of that so yeah um it's pretty small
but everyone's very well I just love uh
as I talk to you guys like these are the
same exact stories uh trials
tribulations successes that uh small
business owners Tech entrepreneurs uh
crypto investors like there's a lot of
people look at the memes and as they're
trying to figure out where we are right
yeah there's a lot of people who like
certain parts of their business and
don't like other parts of the business
and so I appreciate all four of you
coming today uh I think that uh people
hopefully understand that like if I can
take it as far as like I actually think
the porn industry invented the whole
Creator economy and you four are great
examples of that
um and it is this weird thing where uh
as you all progress in your careers you
just kind of hammer home more and more
and more like you're an entrepreneur and
what you did before uh is you know a
decision that you made something that
many of you really enjoyed doing you
learned a lot about yourself all the
stuff but it provided this platform that
all four of you are grabbing and so I
sure you guys coming hopefully everyone
learned a ton but uh
I don't got anything else for you guys
so thank you
[Applause]